to go to our next game Repub drag race
[Applause]
guys beers we've all got them
cats are afraid of water going to
Paltrow's afraid of gluten and
Republicans are terrified of gay wedding
cakes for some reason they say people
can't help who or what they fear but
let's be honest being afraid of a gay
wedding cake is a choice if these stuffy
old farts are a fait are scared of
pastry imagine how terrified they must
be of drag queen
so let's help them get their heart rates
up ladies I would like you to give these
prominent Republicans their very own
drag names first up Steve Bannon ginger
rosacea Oh Donald all right boys
good next up chef session ginger again
Ross Perot no she better down except
senator Ted Cruz velasca the uncouple
kimmy schmitt okay next up Ben Carson
ginger bob the drag wait
[Applause]
mix up everybody's favorite Sean Spicer
cassia Melissa McCarthy ISM all right
boy
[Applause]